>>We have a lot of visitors coming
down, from both in the school
and outside the school, and
they're going to really want
to hear what you have to say.
You're going to bring your
Social Studies notebook,
and articles down there.
If you don't have your
notebook handy, just be prepared
to show them all the articles
on the laptop, and also,
you're going to want to
show them your Google Maps
on the public art sites, okay?
And all of those things, you have
to be prepared to talk about.
Also, we don't want you to forget
those two guiding questions,
how does art reflect the community?
And the other one is,
how does science,
math and engineering connect to art?
>>Susan: It's called Expeditionary
learning for a reason, you know,
the classic expedition, you're
out with a group of people,
trying to climb a mountain,
and the goal,
and all of the consequences
along the way, are real.
It starts to rain.
You know, that happens.
Your computer dies.
That happens.
You know, these things go
on, but you're committed
to this end objective together.
So the relationships
become important,
and the connections become important,
and when you offer someone
the opportunity to engage
in something real, there is
nothing more exhilarating.
>>Scott: At the beginning of
every expedition, we usually look
at a district calendar to see,
you know, what we're going
to be doing for the fall.
>>David: We're talking about a
schedule here at King Middle School
where a team of five or six experts
in learning, your teachers, can say,
in order to pull off this particular
project at this particular stage,
we need to design a whole
new schedule this week.
>>Teacher: The first
one sounded fine.
>> David: If we're working in
the world, and we're in any kind
of engineering or design
process, or editing movies,
nobody stops after 40
minutes, puts everything down
and goes on to do something else.
>>Scott: This is where
we start as a staff,
is creating the model before we ask
the kids to do it, so, essentially,
we kind of figure out what,
exactly, we're going to build.
So here's a good example.
There's, like, a science
piece around metabolism,
and that's a science content piece.
Here's a math piece around
size of their bacteria.
This is a multimedia piece, where
the kids have drawn their work.
>>Ruth: The scientists were
all, like, oh sure, we'll come.
So they're all very
excited to do this.
>>In expeditionary learning, we
love to develop relationships
between the students and community
members, because the excitement
that it generates in the
students, deepens their learning,
and lengthens their retention.
>>Teacher: You have to help
me with the pronunciation.
>>Student: All right,
pseudomonas aurantiaca.
>>Teacher: Aurantiaca.
>>Paul: This is going to take us
to where the maps are in Google,
and then we go to My Maps.
Students are working
with Google Maps,
and they are identifying all
the public art pieces that exist
in the City of Portland,
so that these different
public art sites are going
to be connected as a walking tour.
>>Kate: Hi, I'm Kate.
>>Sarah: I'm Sarah.
>>Student: And this
is Kinetic Conundrums.
>>Sarah: Today, we're
out here taking photos
of already existing public art, that
we're studying in social studies.
And so that we can make art
proposals in language arts,
and then create our own mini
model of public art and click it.
>>Gus: We don't learn
about things, we do things.
It's a lot different than saying,
yeah, I can do that, I understand how
that works, but when they
actually have to do it,
there's a huge learning process,
there's a light bulb,
or an a-ha moment.
>>Drill that hole out
right in the middle.
>>Student: This class is, like,
fun, because they teach us how
to be creative and to make
our own designs so, like,
we will have that experience
as we go along.
>>Gus: It's an incredible
value that I think is lacking,
where they don't have a class like
this, or like an art class, or music,
or something where the kids
actually have to do something,
get their hands dirty and make stuff.
>>David: We get visitors
from lots of schools.
We get the people here from
expeditionary learning schools,
and they'll come in and they'll
look at what we're doing here
at King Middle School,
and they'll say,
"If only we had one-on-one computing,
and they we could do
what you guys are doing."
And then, when the
schools that are interested
in going one-to-one come here,
thinking it was going to be all
about giving kids computers, but
they discover it's really all
about project based learning.
And they say, "If only we
had project based learning,
we could do that, too, but we don't."
>>Let's hear it.
>>David: I say the same
thing to both groups.
You should have both.
There's no excuse for
not having both anymore.
>>Teacher: Last night when I put
all the sculptures, so there's like,
80 sculptures in the front of my
room, and it was really amazing,
thinking of where we started
and where we ended up.
Just the variety of ideas,
and the ingenuity you had.
You should be really proud.
It's just so cool to look
at them all together,
because it's really very cool.
>>David: What do you mean, you did
the math to figure out the balance?
>>Student: Well, this one, which
is two inches, by two inches.
So I did half of that.
>>David: It's pretty exciting to
see the kids get engaged in the work
that they're doing, to take ownership
of the work that they're doing,
feel responsible for it,
and then be able to talk
about the things that
they're learning.
>>So that you have this
side balancing this side.
>>Student: Yeah.
>>David: Sometimes I think we get
too concerned about the standards,
and there's an assumption
behind a lot of that,
that we actually know what our kids
are going to face in the future.
And I'm not very convinced of that.
And so the pieces about creativity,
cooperation, problem solving,
those are going to be there,
and so the kids getting those
here, is crucial and key.
>>Student: It's a weeping willow,
and it's called, Miss Lincoln Tree,
and the name was named after Lincoln
Park, where I want to put this.
>>Teacher: And these
will blow in the wind?
>>Student: Yeah.
It has a little bit of
esthetics, and history based.
>>Teacher: It has a lot of esthetics.
>>Student: Yeah.
>>Teacher: Well I think
you just got my first vote.
>>Student: Oh, thank you.
>>Narrator: For more
information about What Works
In Public Education,
go to edutopia.org.